hi thanks for coming thanks for the
organizers for inviting me this is joint
work with my student Parris similar case
at Stanford while this is not quite on
the topic of fast iterative methods in
optimization I would like to think of as
a tool that could potentially be used in
fast iterative methods and optimization
so there are a lot of good off jargon
and that I let me let me try to decipher
some of that for you let me start with
telling you what the problem that we
consider at this talk okay so it's a
very simple problem it's a very simple
idea and I hope to get that across and I
know I'm the only one keeping you from
lunch so hopefully this will be quick
and light so here's the setup
you're it's a simple problem given a set
of points in D dimensions y1 through yn
there's some potential function which
takes a pair of points and outputs a
value think of this as sort of the
influence of a point it kind of falls
off as you go away from the point that's
this function K X Y the query point X
what your job is is to pre-process this
data set so you have these points y1 to
yn you kept them beforehand you can do
what you want design a data structure to
efficiently answer queries of the
following form ok given a query point X
which itself is a d-dimensional point
we'd like to compute the average
potential K X Y over all the points in
the data set ok so the point X gets a
potential contribution KX y from point y
sum this up over all the points in the
data set average of the data set you
want to compute this so okay it's an
easy problem write it you have endpoints
which is some some of our endpoints the
main question is can we do this any
faster ok if we wanted to estimate what
this value is how should we pre-process
our data
kind of pre-computation can we do so
that a query time when the points X are
presented we can estimate this quantity
very quickly okay that's the problem and
you know what are these potential right
now
you know I said there's some potential
function that takes a pairs of a pair of
points or outputs a value
what are these potentials well one
common potential the people care about
is the Gaussian kernel it's just you
know the probably density function of
the Gaussian ball so e to the power of
minus Euclidean distance squared divided
by Sigma square there are other such
kernels that people think about as well
there's a exponential kernel where
instead of the squared Euclidean
distance you have just the gradient
distance you might have a polynomial
kernel which drops off polynomial e in
the distance and so on but the purpose
of this talk it's useful to keep maybe
just the Gaussian kernel and mine
although I'll mention that song there is
also not relevant to some of the other
kernels as well okay so is the problem
clear it's a very simple problem yeah
what are we assuming about K we know
what K is and that in fact our data
structure will somehow be dependent on K
I see
so actually won't be stating results for
general K but you know all reasonable
kernels are we'll think about decay with
a distance so we think of this as sort
of monotone with distance also radially
symmetric so somehow the kernel depends
on the distance but not the direction
yes that's that's that's a very good
thought if if Sigma is very small then
what does the current look like it's
it's very sharply concentrated very very
close to these points why I write and if
you think of what this kernel value is
really the the contributions are going
to come from the nearest neighbors of of
the point X yeah actually right so in
fact nearest neighbors seem very closely
related to this this problem in fact you
could think of this as some kind of
smooth version of nearest neighbors if
you go okay yeah
why is this interesting or any computer
ok so somebody decided that this was an
interesting problem
maybe I'll I'll tell you I'll give you
one reason why people answer in this but
there's several other instances where
this arises I'm not going to get into
that too much but I'll give you one
reason why yeah ok it's very related to
multiple methods and we'll say that in a
second there's something called fast
multipole method etc etc and we'll come
to that in a few slides down so
hopefully I'll answer both of you I know
that was a very unsatisfactory answer ok
so why do we care about this you know so
there's a in statistics people care
about this kind of problem where there's
some kind of underlying density function
ok we get samples from this density
think of the y1 y2 yn a samples from the
density and based on these samples I'd
like to approximate or estimate this
probably the density function so given a
new point X I'd like to know what's the
value of this density function at the
point x given that i have access to
these samples y1 to yn ok
now this is a very basic problem and
depending on exactly how you phrase it a
variety of different techniques have
been developed to prop to attack this
problem in one common technique that
especially people in in computer science
have weighed on quite a bit is where you
assume that you're probably density has
a certain form let's say it's a mixture
of gaussians ok and then you try to find
what are the parameters of these
Gaussian and there's been a lot of
analysis into trying to understand when
can we do this how many samples do we
need and so on and so forth now in an
entire field of nonparametric statistics
but you make no assumptions about the
unlined density or try to make minimal
assumptions ice about the underlying
density and still you'd like to be able
to say that here's a method that gives
you an approximation to what this online
density is okay so in this field of
nonparametric statistics this particular
method the kind of problem that I
described in the previous slide is in
fact a subroutine
in trying to estimate the population
okay and they're also the theorems that
say that you know if your density
satisfies these properties if you have
so many samples and you would in fact
get estimates that are good okay so
that's one reason why we might care
about okay another reason why and
related to this is is outlier detection
okay so you're given a bunch of points
you don't have a good idea what this
just what distribution they come from
you don't really care about the
distribution per se but what you'd like
to do is give it a new point you like to
figure out you know is this unusual or
not is this should you think of this as
an outlier or is this a typical point
given the data that you've seen so far
okay in fact I mean I was one of the
reasons why we will let to think about
this problem this was this colleague of
mine Peter Bayliss it's at at Stanford
and they developed season eight database
guy and they've developed a system where
you know they deploy sensors in various
places these sensors are making high
dimensional measurements sending them
across and what you'd like to do is be
able to monitor monitor this high-speed
data stream and be able to flag outliers
we like to know that something unusual
is happening okay but these are deployed
in in very very diverse settings you
don't have precise information you don't
want to make assumptions about what kind
of distribution that data is coming from
just based on the observation that you
have so far and based on this new point
you'd like to be able to say you know is
this an outlier or not okay and what
kinds of methods will they use well
these guys for example we're really
using kernel density methods okay that's
one of the reasons why we started
thinking about this problem okay alright
so you know just to give you a sense of
what this might look like here we have a
2d sample so if we have a 2d data set
which was sampled from some particular
density this happens to be the density
of a sample from now the first thing to
do is to just think of your sample as
being
you know have a point density at every
sample point and zero everywhere else
hopefully this is a bad approximation
this is in no sense a good way to think
about what this underlying density is
right so what kind of density estimation
does is well it's smooth this think of
this is a smoothing method right instead
of having sorry stead of having these
point wise Peaks you smooth it out with
a nice Gaussian function or some other
function and average this okay a lot
depends on how wide the so-called
bandwidth of this kernel is right so for
example if you choose something that's
very low bandwidth very narrow exactly
the setting that Ravi was talking about
then you still get something which has
many peaks it's still focused very
closely on the data points okay on the
other hand if you do something that's
very high bandwidth then smooth things
out too much it might might lose some
structure in your underlying density
okay so there's a lot of ingenuity and
there's a lot of thought going into
figuring out what the right bandwidth is
okay and we won't actually focus on
these kinds of questions in this talk so
what what we're going to assume is all
this is done someone's figured out you
know what the right bandwidth is and now
we're faced with the algorithmic
question of trying to actually evaluate
what this kernel density and how quickly
can we do it so well there are many
other settings as well where you know
you have you have the set up where you
have a bunch of data points you have a
query point and you'd like to compute
something which looks like the sum a sum
of terms and each term in the summation
is is a function that takes two
parameters the data point the query
point X and some data point Y okay so
for example in machine learning there's
a the softmax function arises very
frequently here's one one kind of
setting given these these n D
dimensional points y1 to yn given this
query point X you'd like to evaluate
this particular function okay now
ignoring the log and ignoring the one
over beta this summation is just e to
the power of beta times inner product of
x and y and as beta gets large this
value the limit of this value is just a
maximum inner product of x and y so this
is sort of a soft soft version of this
Max inner product and again you know it
would be nice if you can estimate this
quantity quickly this would be very
useful for all kinds of settings another
kind of example is in stochastic
gradient descent where let's say you
have a set of examples y1 to yn you have
some sort of loss function L and the
loss function is just the sum of terms
where each term comes from some function
that combines X with y I one of the data
points ok so let's say you want to
actually minimize this kind of summation
one way to do this is to do the
stochastic gradient design
ok and for this you want to compute the
gradient of this sum the gradient of the
sum of loss functions it's a kind of
stochastic gradient descent instead of
actually computing the true gradient you
just take an estimate of the gradient
and proceed along along those lines it
would be nice if you had a good estimate
if you had a better quality estimate
that would lead to better convergence
and so on okay so the opéra typical
problem for this talk is going to be the
following as I said before you have a
set of points y1 to yn you have some
potential K X Y which for our purposes
is couldn't be the let's say the
Gaussian you can think of something else
if you like and we want to just average
this kernel contribution over all the
points in the data set ok and we're
going to give up on trying to compute
this exactly we want an approximation
what kind of guarantee that we want
let's say we want a multiplicative
guarantee we want to guarantee that our
estimate is within a 1 plus epsilon
factor of the right answer
okay that's the problem as I said we'll
focus on this Gaussian kernel that's it
all right so let me say a little bit
about what's what's known about this
problem there's actually quite a bit of
work in the batch model so the way I
define the problem you have endpoints
they're given to you and then you get a
sequence of queries I didn't want to
evaluate the value of the kernel at each
of these queries the batch model is one
where you have endpoints the endpoints
are the query ism selves what you'd like
to do is you'd like to figure out what's
the net effect of this set of end points
on each of those endpoints okay and this
kind of thing this kind of problem
arises in n-body simulation okay you
have a set of n particles and you'd like
to evaluate what's the gravitational or
the magnetic or electrical force on each
of each of these and you so you have
endpoints and you want to actually
evaluate the net effect of these
endpoints on each of these endpoints
okay the naive solution in this case is
something that's quadratic right because
there are n square pairs you want to
evaluate all of these pairs try to
evaluate this thing would we take N
squared I'm surprisingly for this
problem you can actually do much better
okay so you can get good approximations
to this problem that run in in depending
on exactly what the potential is either
linear time and sometimes n log n time
okay and this is pretty remarkable it
this was breakthrough work in the early
90s late 80s by big garden strain they
did this for for in cases where the
function area we're evaluating is a
Gaussian this is called a fast Gauss
transform it's now a very standard
technique numerical analysis there's
also a class of methods called
fast multiple methods that Pablo
mentioned by green garden Rocklin which
applies to more general functions and
the Gaussian okay in fact this this is
really a highly regarded work this was
awarded the 2001 Steele Prize
and it was also selected as one of the
top ten algorithms of the 20th century
by the editors of computing in science
and engineering
so in numerical analysis this is really
a very very very important achievement
so what exactly do these these fast
multipole methods do they're really
solving our problem but in this batch
setting you know in theory world in
computer science theory there's related
work called the well separated pair
decomposition this is very similar ok by
Callahan and coach Rajan okay so our
high-level what are these methods doing
okay at a high level all of these
methods are some sort of spaced
decomposition methods that in a second
yes the short answer is yes any other
question
they're actually not exciting so it is
exponential what they're doing is
they're partitioning their space
partitioning methods okay so the
partition space and the rough idea is
that if you try to evaluate the net
effect let's say of you know on one
particular particle here if you look at
stuff that's far away then you don't
need to know that these are all separate
particles you can actually coalesce them
to one okay and the approximation that
you introduce in doing so is pretty
small okay that's the main idea so the
main idea is that you can look at you
can you can look at portions of the
space at a very far away and you don't
need to know the precise locations of
the particles and in in those in that
far away portion you just you can
coalesce them into one okay and by
considerations of this nature you can
actually reduce the total number of
calculations to not from quadratic down
to linear and sometimes I'm longer
that's the main idea the caveat is that
if you look at these bounds
they depend exponentially on the
dimension right when GREENGUARD and
Rocklin were developing these methods
they were really designed for
two-dimensional three-dimensional spaces
in fact if you stretch them to higher
dimensional spaces then the exponent the
dependence on the on the dimension is
exponential okay so you'll get log 1
over epsilon raised to power of D
something else now in our setting we're
really interested in high dimensional
data so this is not an option okay
okay so recap here's our problem you
have a bunch of points you have a query
point X you want to evaluate this
average kernel contribution from all of
your endpoints to within an accuracy of
1 plus Epsilon okay so how do you do it
just doesn't quite help because yeah
you'll get the dimension down to log n
over epsilon squared but your
exponential in the dimension so that's
not going to help yeah in general okay
so how would you do it you know you have
to evaluate this quantity within 1bizapp
salon approximation do it faster than
evaluating all of the endpoints what's
the first thing that will come to mind
oh yeah so the first thing you think
about is random something okay so let's
think about random sampling um so for
our problem how many samples do we need
to get a 1 plus epsilon approximation
okay
so I'm going to introduce a new
parameter I'm going to say suppose the
answer is mu and let's say all of our
kernel values are values between 0 & 1
this is true of these are densities
right so all our kxy terms are between 0
& 1 and that's a the average happens to
be mu and I can characterize the number
of samples that I need as a function of
MU the random sampling it turns out that
the number of samples that I need is one
over epsilon squared times 1 over mu ok
1 over epsilon squared term is pretty
standard if you want a 1 plus epsilon
approximation you're going to be stuck
with a 1 over epsilon squared term it's
this 1 over mu term that I'm I'm going
to focus on so why actually why does
random sampling need 1 over mu
so if you think about it you know the
average of these large number of zero
one terms is mu but that could come
about because only mu fraction of them
have a very large contribution
everything else is almost zero in this
setting for the random sample to even
hit something with a large value you're
gonna need about 1 over mu samples it's
a random sampling is gonna take one of
them here so now the question is can we
do any better can we improve on a random
sampling does
important sampling exactly so before I
talk about important sampling let me
mention one more thing now in this talk
we've only talked about multiplicative
approximations that's not that if you if
you think about additive approximation
there's been some results on that as
well if you're willing to live with an
additive epsilon approximation turns out
that there are results that say that you
can do this with a small set of
something like 1 over epsilon squared
points okay so let's let's come to Ken's
idea of using important sampling okay so
what's the basic idea so let's say I
have you know I I have this summation
which involves n terms let's say WI is
the I term WI is just a kernel
contribution of the I point why I okay
and I want to estimate this summation of
W I do within 1 plus Epsilon okay in
uniform sampling I pick an I index are
uniformly random an important sampling I
pick I with some probability Qi which
I'm going to figure out what what it
should be okay so I'm gonna sample I
with probably Qi and then I'm gonna look
at this weight WI I'm gonna bias correct
I'm going to divide by Qi so I'm gonna
report WI by Qi so thinking this is a
random variable if I sample I with
probably Qi and I report WI back UI so
by design the expectation of my random
variable is just the sum of it of you
guys this is an unbiased estimator of
the sum of the Wis what's the point of
having these probabilities Qi the point
is having these probably skew eyes
allows me to reduce the variance of this
estimator
actually what is what's a good siding on
these Q eyes how should I set these Qi
is you look to get the smallest possible
variants
you should set the Q is proportional to
the W ice okay it turns out that if you
compute what's the second moment of this
estimator its summation of W I squared
divided by Q I okay
and we do a little bit of analysis if we
haven't seen this before you realize the
best setting of the Q is is that the Q
eyes ought to be proportional to the W
eyes okay in fact if you're able to do
this exactly the variance of this
estimator is zero
the variance is that lose zero but there
are many reasons why we cannot actually
achieve this okay for one thing I mean
even evaluating what these Qi czar would
require knowing what the some of the W
eyes are which is exactly the quantity
that we started our estimating so in our
case this gives us a good benchmark and
this gives us something that we should
try to achieve so the point is if you
want to improve on random sampling we
should possibly think of sampling points
in some biased way so that points that
have higher weight higher contribution
have higher probability of being sampled
and this analysis says that ideally the
probability that the eighth point is
sample should be proportional to its
contribution that's the message we want
it okay of course the question is how do
we design such a sampling scheme I mean
these weights WI are really the you know
unknown we don't have them beforehand
these are the ones that we want to you
want to compute that some we don't have
actually have access to these widths
okay so that's what that's the problem
if we're gonna try to solve okay alright
so quick interlude
I'm gonna recap something that Alex
mentioned in this talk and this is
related to what are we mentioned to so
intuitively this problem of kernel
density estimation seems somewhat
related to nearest neighbor search ok if
in fact our kernel was very much
concentrated on the data points it seems
like nearest neighbor search is sort of
the right thing to do right the the
nearest neighbors of the data point X of
the query X are really the ones that
give you the largest contribution okay
now as our expansion as a very
influential technique called locality
sensitive hashing that was introduced in
late 90s by Indyk and motwani and the
building block for these for the scheme
is the idea that if you had a hash
function family
that somehow distinguishes between near
points and fire points it has a higher
collision probability for points at a
nearby lower collision probably four
points at a far-away then this can serve
as a building block a useful building
block for designing a data structure for
nearest neighbor search okay basically
the idea is that you design a hash table
using these hash functions and this hash
table can serve as a very useful data
structure first for answering nearest
neighbor search queries so usually in
this nearest neighbor world it turns out
that you know solving or proving things
about exact nearest neighbor is very
difficult instead people to relax the
problem and say I'm willing to get a C
approximate nearest neighbor if your
nearest neighbor is distance R I'm happy
to get something which is just since C
times R okay and again as Alex mentioned
you know the the key thing that people
analyze in this business is let's say
you have some distance threshold are
you'd like it to be the case that if you
have two points x and y that are less
than you are apart then the collision
probability is high if you have points
that are C times R apart or more then
the collision probability is low okay if
you had such a hash family you saw you
pick many such hash functions
concatenate their values think of that
as your hash address build your hash
tables in fact build on one hash table
put multiple hash tables and that's how
your nearest neighbor search queries are
answered
okay what's you know eventually in this
in this business what you care about is
you know how quickly can you answer
queries and how many hash tables do you
have so the number of hash tables and
the number of and the query time is
really closely related to how different
you can make P and Q okay how much you
can separate P and Q and the precise way
in which this the dependence is is Rho
is actually log 1 over P over log 1 over
Q it's not only important for us but in
in this approximate nearest neighbor
literature the main focus is trying to
understand how this parameter Rho
relates to see ok what's what's the best
dependence between row and C in a lot of
work has been going into figuring this
out should give you an example of how
you know elevators become mainstream
this is a this is a figure from paper in
science from two years ago where people
are using LSH to detect earthquakes okay
so they have these multiple sensors
they're looking at the waveforms or each
of them detect and then they're they're
actually searching for this particular
waveform in each of these hash tables so
what you do is you you take hash table
one hash table two hash table three look
at the bucket that the query falls into
take the union of those buckets those
are your candidates you evaluate them
the best candidates from that set is
your answer okay all right so let me
give you a quick very quick run-through
of some examples of these hash function
right now you know there's some it seems
to be some magic in these hash functions
in fact I like showed you some hash
functions I'll remind you what the -
functions look like one common setting
is where you have your data consists of
unit vectors okay so let's say your data
consists of unit vectors and you care
about the angle between them okay so
here's a simple hash function that works
in that setting just pick a random
vector R take dot product with you and
report the sine
okay the nice thing about this sign is
that the probability that U and V have
different signs is directly proportional
to the angle between them it's actually
just the angle divided by pi okay
so this is a simple hash function that I
introduced many years ago at Google the
hash value is just one bit you
concatenate many such hash functions to
produce your hash address another one
was introduced by data or more Lika
Indyk and mere opening very simple hash
function here this works for D
dimensional data in Euclidean space you
project your data down to a line okay
partition the line into buckets of size
W with a random shift okay and just
remember the ID of the bucket that you
fell into that's one hash function you
can't catenate many such hash function
so that's that's one it's a very common
LSH function
another LSH functions introduced by Alex
and Piatra in 2006 they went one step
further so the previous one projected
your data down to one line to one
dimension what they did was they
projected into T dimensional space where
T is some large enough constant now they
took this T dimensional space and
partitioned it into balls and somehow
the fact that they used balls more
closely mirrors the geometry of l2 okay
and for this they can show that the
parameter Rho that they achieve is
something like 1 over c-squared as I
said in this business the main thing
that people worry about is how large is
Rho as a function of C
it turns out this is actually optimum
for l2 recently there's been a
resurgence of interest in analysis in
particular there were several there were
lower bounds on these on these other
state schemes that we've now managed to
break through by somehow exploiting the
structure of the data okay so these
previous LSH constructions but I didn't
look at the data at all they just build
your hash tables but these new rs8
constructions actually say well no no we
should actually look at the data let's
divide it up into pieces and then do
separate schemes on each of these pieces
and doing that you can get even further
improvements okay anyway this was a
quick quick sort of detour into locality
sensitive hashing and this is done this
is gonna turn out to be a useful
primitive for us okay with a twist okay
so remember we were we we stopped when
we came up with this idea of important
sampling we said well how just how are
we going to implement important sampling
in our setting okay
and the key idea is that the cardi
Sandra washing gives us a way to
implement this kind of biased sampling
scheme that we're looking for okay and
in fact a similar idea appears in the
work of spring and srivasa recently it's
okay so you know what does that Sh give
us okay and let's each gives us a handle
on gives us a way to design a hash table
okay well we can control by choosing
appropriate hash function the collision
probability the probability that x and y
end up in the same hash bucket okay we
can think of the set of okay so once we
build a hash table we look at our query
X we also map it to the hash table we
can think of the set of elements that
ended up in the same bucket as the query
as a biased sample of the rate outside
okay and this in principle is useful
right this the question is can we
somehow users to implement this priority
sampling scheme that we we were hoping
to implement earlier so Alice it gives
us a way to extract a by a sample of the
data
and could this potentially be useful in
our priority sampling scheme that we
handle you the caveat is that you know
when we analyze priority sampling we
assume the important sampling we assume
that the probability of sampling element
I is Qi and we assume that all these
probabilities were independent okay so
we assume there was there was no there's
no dependence if you try to do this
using LSH there's gonna be a lot of
dependence because of all the elements
that end up in the hash bucket we can
pick one okay so we don't quite have the
same some properties that we were hoping
to have in our priorities in our
important sampling but still it seems
like it's it's potentially useful okay
so let me tell you what we do so we take
our any other site scheme okay we build
our hash table we take the query X we
map it to its hash bucket we pick one of
the elements of the hash bucket at
random and evaluate its kernel
contribution that's exactly what we do
all right so how do we analyze this so
earlier for priority sampling we had
this very you know we said we have this
probability distribution Qi we're gonna
report the kernel contribution of of
this point that we sample divided by Qi
okay what are the Qi is in this case so
now you know earlier we said when we
analyze important sampling it seemed
like the right thing to do was to set
our collision probabilities some are
proportional to the kernel they sounds
like that's that's that's the right
thing to do that's what important
something suggested but if we do this
Alice ate schemer I described what's the
probability of sampling weii okay so
let's say I populated my hash table
right in our sample weii weii needs to
land in the same hash bucket as the
query X so
probably that that happens is the
collision probability okay but then if a
whole bunch of other elements ended up
in the same hash but I'm gonna pick only
one of them the probably that I pick why
I in particular is one over the size of
the hash bucket okay so this is that
this is what cute them this is or the
analog of Qi that I had before
now I can control the numerator
numerator is something I control because
I I can design my hashing scan choose my
hashing scheme and control the numerator
the denominator on the other end is
something which seems much more
complicated right because it depends on
the structure of the data set and the
hashing scheme there's not clear how we
can control that right so it's not clear
how we should you know analyze this sort
of LSH based scheme turns out that if
you analyze the the second moment of the
estimator that you get so first of all
the estimator is unbiased as before the
second moment you know earlier we had
just this expression this is the
expression that we had for for important
sampling now we have a second term and
the second term is the expected size of
the hash bucket
okay this figures in the in the
expectation
still it's not okay so we can come with
this expression but it's not clear how
to analyze it right so a couple of
things that actually make the analysis
tractable one is that it turns out that
for any hashing scheme if you look at
this expression of second moment and say
what's the worst configuration that I
could have what's the what's the
configuration of points that maximizes
the second moment then it's a it's a
very simple two point configuration
where all of the data set is at one of
two distances from the query X so once
you have this very nice structure
theorem you can actually analyze what is
the maximum possible value of the second
moment and secondly a natural family of
schemes is those where the collision
probability is somehow related to the
corner not exactly the kernel but it's
proportional its it behaves like the
kernel raised to the power of beta okay
and so for such schemes we have a way to
analyze the variance the variance of
this estimator is has a very nice
expression now using this and going back
and analyzing all of those previous
allocated constructions the raters
described in this setting turns out that
we can get good bounds on how many
samples we need okay so for the Gaussian
kernel if you plug in the Euclidean lsh
that I described before we project onto
a single line it turns out that the
query complexity is 1 over mu to the 3/4
so there's an improvement over the
random sampling bound or one of them you
if you use the optimum scheme of
Antonian Indic it turns out that you get
1 over square root of mu for the
exponential kernel again you get 1 over
square root of mu also for the
polynomial kernel you get 1 over square
root of MU okay so for all of these
kernels you can actually improve on the
the usual the random deny random
sampling math
how's the exponent to lane in a row
these things oh so you're saying you
know usually Alice I just analyze from
the point of view of what's the
relationship of row and C there's no
direct relationship as far as I can tell
okay so for all of these analyses we we
had to sort of go back and reanalyze
these schemes it's not clear to me and
Lisa I don't know of a way to take an LS
H theorem as a black box and say if you
plug it into our scheme you know here's
what you would get okay so you really
had to go back and analyze these things
I mean it's sort of interesting that in
this case plugging in what is known to
be a better at I said scheme for L 2
actually gives you an improvement right
but for the exponential economy you
don't need to do that it turns out
through exponential kernel this came the
original scheme which is not optimal for
L 2 is actually good enough so there's
something more going on it's not quite
the same
okay and so that's why I said it forces
you to read you know look again at Alice
H from this point of view it seems to be
somewhat different point of view then
it's been looked at before I should say
one more thing I mean you know we've
expressed our running times as a
function of MU okay turns out that we
can actually make that work so it turns
out that you can design a scheme where
if your mu is large you will you will
indeed realize that very quickly whereas
if mu is small you will run for longer
so you can actually express the query
time as a function of the value mu that
you're trying to estimate okay you can
make that work we can do a little bit
more at one say much about it turns out
that if you're you know the worst case
data sets in our analysis are really
where all of the data is clustered in
one spot and if we have pseudo-random
data sets where this is not the case the
data spread out somewhat we can actually
take advantage of that and give better
bounds there are some lower bounds that
you can get in the batch setting for
this problem assuming the strong
exponential time hypothesis
won't say much about that let me just
mention I know I'm running over time and
we mentioned just a few glimpses of some
ongoing work that we've been doing so
one thing we've realized since we did
this initially was that you know I gave
the running time for various car notes
and it turns out that the rate at which
the carnal decay is really plays a role
in how many queries you need okay so if
you have a polynomial kernel okay so our
previously I said you need 1 over root
mu don't do that you can actually make
this work in poly logarithmic time so 1
over root Mew could still be pretty bad
right if you could be as bad as 1 over n
but turns out that you can actually
evaluate this in polyrhythmic query time
[Music]
yes the exponent of the log depends on
exponent of the polynomial in the car
another thing that we managed to do and
we're still working on this is you know
I focused on this exponential kernel in
general you might want to evaluate sums
of terms where each term is of the form
e to the power of some function of the
inner product and turns out that this
can also be done okay I mean I'm being
very deliberately busy I'm quite worked
out all the details but turns out we can
actually adapt these H idea as to
estimate more general functions
it seems very plausible although we
haven't quite any other details so some
of these ideas that have been used for
data dependent LS it should also be
useful and they're starting to give you
improved bounds although we haven't
quite dotted the i's and cross the t's
here and finally this is a very simple
scheme I mean it's a it's a very it's
it's a it's an implementation of
importance are playing via SSH okay
and it seems like this should be very it
should be something is very practical
and easy to experiment with so I'm
hoping that you know a few months later
we will actually have some experiments
to report on using these methods in
comparison with some of the other
methods that are out there
thank you